françois vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 23 septembre
2001 en fonction des territoires de
nouvelles mesures face au co vide dès
samedi annonce du ministre de la santé
il ya quelques minutes
lille paris toulouse ou encore grenoble
sont placées en zones d'alerté renforcé
les rassemblements ils seront limitées à
10 personnes dans l'espace public
les bars devront fermer à 22 heures
maximum les fêtes locales et étudiantes
seront interdites les salles des fêtes
et polyvalente seront également fermés à
la guadeloupe et la métropole
d'aix-marseille passe elle en zone d'
alerte maximale les bars et restaurants
seront fermés assemblée générale des
nations unies deuxième journée ce
mercredi organisée de façon virtuelle en
raison de la crise sanitaire
une assemblée dominée hier par la
rivalité entre la chine et les états
unis
aujourd'hui parmi les dix courses des
dirigeants du liban de l'algérie de
l'irak et de l'arabie saoudite
[Musique]
bruxelles prône des contrôles renforcés
aux frontières extérieures et plus
d'efficacité sur les retours des
migrants vers leur pays d'origine à la
commission européenne présente son
nouveau pacte sur la migration et
d'asile et ce deux semaines après l
incendie du camp de migrants grecque de
lesbos symbole de l'échec de la
politique migratoire européenne
les ong elles accusent de céder aux pays
les plus hostiles à l'accueil des
réfugiés
[Musique]
non
olivier ferrand a donc tenu son point
presse hebdomadaire sur l'évolution de
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 et de nouvelles
mesures restrictives ont été annoncés
alors pour tout savoir on va rejoindre
tout de suite en direct notre reporter
un mot namouh dès lors devant le
ministère de la santé
mona vous êtes donc devant le ministère
de la santé qu'est ce que l'on peut déjà
retenir de la prise de parole d'olivier
verrons ce soir
bonsoir olivier plusieurs annonces ont
été faites par le ministre de la santé
il l'a dit la situation continue de se
dégrader le virus est toujours aussi
dangereux il l'a dit 69 départements
sont en alerte rouge soit 7 sur 10
plusieurs mesures ont été annoncées ces
annonces et bien elles seront validées
et concertée avec les préfets de chaque
de chaque région notamment à paris lille
lyon ou encore bordeaux qui sont en
alerte renforcée à marseille ou encore
la guadeloupe sont en alerte maximale
ces mesures et bien elles seront
appliquées pendant quinze jours elles
peuvent être renouvelées ou pas tout
dépend de la situation de l'épidémie par
exemple les fêtes les mariages les
anniversaires devront se tenir au petit
comité pas plus de 30 personnes équipées
seule une disposition est désormais et
sera désormais imposé à tous ses
départements rouge les fêtes les
mariages les tombolas les événements
associatifs les anniversaires les
communions devront se tenir en petit
comité
c'est à dire à moins de 30 personnes les
salles polyvalentes des salles des fêtes
et les autres établissements recevant ce
type d'événement devront respecter cette
jauge de 30 personnes dans les zones en
alerte renforcée notamment pour paris
lyon ou encore bordeaux les barbus et
bars et restaurants de voulant fermer à
partir de 22h écouter olivero également
un sujet des mesures qui s'appliqueront
à compter de samedi et à l'issue d'une
concertation entre le préfet et les élus
locaux sont les suivantes abaissement de
la jauge des rassemblements à 1000
personnes sous réserve que les
protocoles sanitaires ils soient
strictement respectées
interdiction des grands événements
déclaré comme les fêtes locales ou les
fêtes étudiantes l'interdiction des
rassemblements de plus de 10 personnes
dans l'espace public tels que plage parc
fermeture anticipée des bars l'horaire
de fermeture étant décidée par le préfet
après concertation des élus
cette mesure sur les barres entrera en
vigueur lundi pour laisser le temps
utile à cette concertation
en tout état de cause les bars ne
pourront pas rester ouverts au delà de
22 heures dans l'ensemble de ces
territoires
vous l'avez entendu
et mesures qui vont encore prendre
quelques jours à être instauré des
concertations vont être engagées avec
des préfets afin de peaufiner de
préciser toutes ces mesures le ministre
de la santé a également encouragé le
télétravail doit être favorisée dans les
métropoles dans les corps de métier ou c
c'est possible si la situation se
dégrade et bien les territoires devront
rentrer en état d'urgence sanitaire pour
le moment ce n'est pas le cas en france
et puis des mesures vont être appliquées
à partir de ce samedi je vous disais ou
à partir de lundi cela pendant quinze
jours des mesures qui pourraient être
prolongées ou pas tout dépend de
situations épidémiques en fonction des
jeans
merci beaucoup mona pour toutes ces
précisions mona ramouni dès lors en
direct devant le ministère de la santé
pour revenir sur les nouvelles mesures
annoncées par olivier ferrand nous
retrouvons tout de suite nos invités et
nous sommes et nous sommes ce soir avec
virginie martin politologue professeur à
laquelle business school bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
à vos côtés thierry amouroux
porte-parole syndicats infirmiers snpi
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france et
pour nous livrer aussi son témoignage
nous rejoindre à tout à l'heure marcel
bénézet il est président des cafés bars
brasseries syndicats gn il thierry
amouroux je me tourne vers vous pour
commencer bonsoir
thierry amouroux alors on va commencer
avec vous thiery team marcel bénézet
pardon tirelire ou alors bien voilà vous
m'entendez alors une des mesures
annoncées ce soir c'est la fermeture des
bars fermés à 22h donc dans les zones
d'alert fermeture totale des bars et des
restaurants à partir de samedi est ce
que vous comprenez cette décision bien
[Musique]
que vous dire le virus devient tout d'un
seul coup plus virulent à 22h qu'avait
été 1h59 c'est voilà nous ce que l'on
attend du du gouvernement c'est qu'il
soit beaucoup plus clair dans ses
consignes alors que là c'est difficile
d'avoir l'accord de la population sur
des des consignes qui semble un peu
curieuse donc du coup à 21h59 les gens
doivent se précipiter dans les
transports en commun bondés mais ça
n'est pas un souci ça juste justement
virginie martin est ce que vous y voyez
un paradoxe
thierry amouroux le soulignait on peut
voir aux heures de pointe beaucoup de
monde dans les transports en commun et
puis ce soir on a cette annonce de
nouvelles mesures basées sur beaucoup
moins d'interactions sociales finalement
comment vous ne comprenez c'est à dire
c'est c'est difficile à comprendre parce
que là le gouvernement doit
impérativement faute d'avoir
correctement anticipée après le
confinement donc avoir correctement géré
le déconfinement ceux des confinement a
été extrêmement mal gérée pour le voit
aujourd'hui de toute façon on en a la
preuve donc il doit être dans une
communication de crise rassurante et
enfin que cette communication de crise
elle se veut tellement rassurante
tellement peu clair qu'elles ont fini
par être pas clair vous voyez pour pas
créer l'anxiété ou le côté anxiogène
finalement on met plein de mots des
graphiques des cartes des sur carte d re
carte au rouge foncé en rouge clair
rouge écarlate ans ça devient absolument
insupportable
les messages ne sont pas claires et donc
le manque de clarté va encore créer de
la confusion parce que le gouvernement a
besoin d'un choc de confiance pour que
la population adhère
à ces mesures nous avons tous s'cusez
moi adhérer au confinement
vous comprenez bien que là ça si je peux
dire son crédit au crédit d'adhésion il
est à zéro aujourd'hui pour le
gouvernement
donc il fallait aussi créé un choc de
confiance plus grand et là on sent tout
de suite que le messager déliter il est
des lits délétère aussi il est reçu de
manière assez critique tout de suite en
fait quand on regarde les réseaux
sociaux ça s'enflamme tout de suite
il prend la pression est ce qu'on n'a
pas aussi un peu l'impression de revenir
un peu en arrière au moment de ces
points quotidiens pendant le confinement
justement qu'ils étaient eux aussi
considérés comme anxiogène finalement
oui bien sûr mais pas parce qu'aussi
rats il ya eu un confinement puis après
un dea confinement il fallait gérer
après ça il fallait gérer petit pas à
petit pas qu'est ce qui s'est passé on a
ouvert les vannes complètement monsieur
déconfinement est devenu premier
ministre en une semaine dix jours et
après ça a été l'été où on a décidé que
c'était l'été de tous les dangers
forcément pour septembre bat wil alors
qu'on aurait dû faire beaucoup plus
attention que le gouvernement révèle
beaucoup plus anticipateur beaucoup un
meilleur gestionnaire si je puis dire en
bon père en bonne mère de famille nous
avons eu un gouvernement démissionnaire
pendant deux mois et un président de
république aussi forcément que
maintenant on rattrape
on est toujours en train de courir après
virus après cette histoire
la politique c'est anticiper c'est pas
possible autrement
alors on va retrouver marcel bénézet
voilà il nous a rejoint président des
cafés bars brasseries syndicats gn et
alors peut-être votre réaction sur cette
annonce du soir fermeture totale des
bars et restaurants à marseille dans les
zones d' alerte rouge écarlate si on
peut les appeler comme ça quelle est
votre réaction
vous la comprenez
réaction une réaction est un peu de
colère parce que nous reste nous avons
un protocole sanitaire que nous
respectons scrupuleusement donc
aujourd'hui fermé nos établissements
nous à 22h je pense que c'est une grave
erreur parce que nous allons avoir tout
ce public qui vont se retrouver dans des
jardins dans les squares dans des
espaces publics avec des boissons
alcoolisées sans contrôle je pense que
l'erreur fait fausse route l'état fait
fausse route
je pense qu'il doit nous laisser gérer
une situation que nous connaissons
parce que nous avons quand même
l'habitude de gérer ce jardine ce genre
de 2,2 de nous nos deux établissements
donc nous avons l'habitude donc il faut
nous laisser travailler parce que le
fermer nous établissements maintenant ça
veut dire que le service du soir est
condamné c'est jeter nous c'est jeter
nos établissements dans un gouffre où
nous sommes déjà aujourd'hui je suis
très inquiet pour la profession nous
sommes déjà à genoux et là c'est celle
où j'étais dans le gouffre et on s'en
remettra pas donc et nous gérons la
situation
je pense que ses parents de services à
la jeunesse que de les laisser partir
après 22 heures sans aucun établissement
ouvert ils vont consommer dans des
conditions insupportables et se mettre
en danger sa sont là dans les
appartements dans des lieux confinés
chez eux d'un des petit studio parce que
ce sont les étudiants qui arrivent à
paris et je pense qu'il vaut mieux
qu'ils soient chez nous que dans des
espaces privés tirer amouroux vous aide
soignant vous êtes le porte parole
syndical je le rappelle un fermier snp
olivier viron l'a rappelé ce soir la
tension qu'il y a à l'heure actuelle
dans les hôpitaux une tension qui
revient est ce que vous comprenez ce que
vient de nous dire marcel bénézet rose
en nous on maîtrise on sait faire
finalement c'est mieux que de laisser
les jeunes traîner un peu partout dans
la rue et peut-être avec plus de
contamination quel est votre regard sur
ce que vient de dire marcel bénézet oui
tout à fait c'est ce que l'on ressent
aussi nous on préférerait que le l'état
se concentre sur donner les moyens aux
hôpitaux de pouvoir répondre à la
deuxième vague de donner les moyens aux
soignants d'avoir le matériel de
protection nécessaire alors qu'on est en
tension depuis début juin sur les gants
médicaux sur les sur blue sur les
masques bon sens du matériel il vous
manque encore du matériel aujourd'hui
c'est ce que vous nous dites on est en
tension alors qu' il y avait une faible
activité infectieuses comprenez que des
vous êtes en pic infectieux le la
consommation est multiplié par dix donc
en quelques jours on va se retrouver de
nouveau avec des sacs poubelles sur le
dos tout ça parce que le gouvernement
est incapable de faire ce qu'on attend
de lui qu'on lui demande depuis le mois
de mars à savoir de réquisitionner des
usines textiles pour que dieu de
fabriquer de la lingerie elle fasse les
les gants les masques et tout le
matériel dont nous avons besoin parce
que là on est toujours dans la pensée
magique
je lancerai une commande et puis la
chine fournira ah bah non parce que vous
avez tous les pays du monde qui commande
en même temps le même type de matériel
donc il ya de la tension
donc il faut fabriquer sur le sol
français
le matériel nécessaire aux soignants
français pour répondre aux besoins de
santé des français
virginie martin c'est ce manque
d'anticipation la dont vous parliez tout
à l'heure dont il s'agit on aurait pu
anticiper justement la fabrication en
france du matériel nécessaire en cas
d'une éventuelle seconde vague et bien
sûr c'est c'est tellement évident je le
répète
gouverner c'est avant tout anticiper
c'est gérer ces situations de crise
c'est y être prêts y est préparé
alors est ce que le gouvernement par
finalement line expérimentation
l'inexpérience excusez-moi de ses
ministres du président de la république
lui-même finalement sont confrontés à
quelque chose qui les dépasse c'est ça
aussi qui créent
le côté anxiogène de cette affaire parce
que comme ça a été dit précédemment
depuis le mois de mars vous savez on
pouvait peut-être pardonner certains
pardonner au gouvernement à l'exécutif
assibat hendaia agnès buzyn à emmanuel
macron lui-même au mois de mars quand
ils ont dit excusez nous on nous étions
pas prêt mais au moins de septembre
fin septembre qui quand le faire croire
que nous ne sommes pas prêts à part
parce que nous n'avons rien fait c'est
quand même très étonnant voyez il ya
aussi un peu de bon sens à faire et ce
soir quand on entend lille et veyran on
aurait peut-être aimé alors pas
forcément que sur toutes les mesures moi
je ne suis pas là pour juger les mesures
je suis pas ni médecin ni n'y aura ni
épidémiologie épidémiologue et tout ce
genre de choses évidemment
mais mais juste le bon sens le bon sens
aurait peut-être aimé entend tout genre
de mesure il ya quinze jours trois
semaines
vous savez moi je suis en direct de
marseille pour qui a été à marseille au
mois d'août et de juillet je vous assure
que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui était
une évidence une évidence pas parce que
la distanciation social rien n'a été
respectée comment vous l'expliquez bah
oui parce que tout le monde s'est il
réjoui
et 30% de plus de touristes à marseille
et puis voilà et puis de la bonne
activité de la vie de la belle
attractivité ça c'est fabuleux
mais si vous aviez vu enfin c'était
véritablement les modes sur les plages
des ddd des centaines et des centaines
et des centaines de personnes sur des
mètres carrés de plage quand même tout
petit c'est quand même pas les grandes
plages du de biarritz à marseille je
vous le rappelle est il s'était vraiment
accessible oui tendue sur sur le vieux
port il y avait aussi des masses et des
masses de population de touristes de
locaux etc
enfin c'était écrit si je puis dire il
suffisait de regarder
donc voilà leur l'anticipation c'est
dommageable c'est vraiment dommageable
parce que on est obligé de faire
confiance au gouvernement parce que
c'est lui qui a les rênes
lui qui a les mesures les préfets et les
maires et on al'impression un petit peu
mais ça depuis mars à que finalement ce
qui sont les meilleures conseillères de
ces nous mène voilà c'est tiré amour
vous payer quoi aujourd'hui avec la
fermeture des bars et des restaurants on
le rappelle à marseille notamment la
fermeture à 22 heures dans les zones les
zones d' alerte renforcée
vous payez quoi aujourd'hui c'est
finalement l'un discipline des français
pendant les vacances
ou alors c'est un manque d'écouté de
votre part vous n'avez pas été assez
écoutés par le gouvernement pour dire
oui nous on sait faire on peut
accueillir qu'est ce qui s'est passé
bien disons qu'il ya eu une telle
incohérence dans le discours du
gouvernement ou au départ banon les
masses ça servait à rien au départ les
tests non ça servait à rien que
finalement il ya une méfiance qui
déplacés qui s'est installée et que du
coup les gens perdent le bon sens c'est
à dire que ça fait un siècle qu'on sait
que bâle en cas d'épidémie l'idée un
virus respiratoires faut mettre hamas
est bien là avec le cafouillis du
ministre au départ bas il ya des gens
qui doutent lépi après c'est du simple
bon sens quand vous êtes dans un espace
clos barre oui le masque il
indispensable il faut aérer vos
appartements il faut aérer les bureaux
il faut aérer tout ce qu'on peut pour
réduire la concentration de virus et ben
le fait que deux personnes est un masque
le risque de transmission est d'autant
plus limité voilà donc respecter les
mesures barrières c'est ça qui peut
protéger tout le monde parce que c'est
une maladie qui ne
qui n'affecte pas uniquement les
personnes âgées même si ce sont les les
plus frappés il faut bien comprendre que
ben est où tous ces jeunes qui ont
beaucoup échangé là en septembre ils ont
retrouvé leurs collègues plus âgés ils
ont retrouvé leurs parents leurs grands
parents
et c'est pour ça que bas il ya
aujourd'hui une tension dans les
hôpitaux où on voit que que ça monte
progressivement alors c'est pas un
tsunami un com
comme au printemps mais on voit que ça
montre que c'est une pente et donc nous
on est inquiet parce que il faut bien
comprendre que dans le même temps
aujourd'hui nous avons moins de lits
qu'en janvier
parce que le gouvernement a continué sa
politique de fermeture d'établissement
de fermetures de services d'économies de
bouts de chandelles sur sur la santé
même un hôpital aussi symbolique que le
chu de strasbourg
on a fermé 14 lits de réanimation sur ce
deux hôpitaux du chu de strasbourg au
mois de juin donc qu'on nous soignants
on apprend ça mais on tombe des nues
déjà nous avons cinq fois moins de lits
de réanimation que l'allemagne
l'allemagne a vu quatre fois moins de
morts parce qu'ils avaient ri
il avait les lits de réanimation il
avait le personnel nous il ya 30%
d'infirmières de moins en france qu en
allemagne pour 1000 habitants
par contre nous on a 35 %
d'administratifs de plus
donc voilà c'est cette difficulté parce
que on parlait tout à l'heure du manque
de matériel de protection
mais on se retrouve avec les mêmes
problèmes qu'il ya six mois
et puis les masques chirurgicaux cette
fois ci c'est d'autres choses mais nous
on soignant on a payé un lourd tribut
sur la première fac
rien que sur une île établissement qui
un petit échantillonnage du nombre
d'hôpitaux et des bas dans france il y à
31 et les soignants qui vont été
contaminés et victime du coville
effectivement du coup marcel bénézet je
me tourne vers vous également je vous
pose finalement la même question vous
est ce que vous payez aussi pour
finalement ses vacances où les gens
peut-être au moins respecter les
distanciation social comme je disais
tout à l'heure est ce que vous avez
finalement là ce sentiment d'être des
victimes est ce que vous êtes
suffisamment écoutés par le gouvernement
est ce que vous avez pu élaborer un
dialogue avec eux justement pour éviter
ces fermetures et pour faire des
propositions mais nous les propositions
les en fait je suis je suis en tournée
je suis entend plus je ne comprends pas
parce que je pensais pas qu'on nous
faire à même de deux heures parce que ce
n'était pas à l'ordre du jour
je pense que c'est une grave erreur et
je passe fermer nos établissements à 22h
je pense qu'on va mettre dans la rue
tous ces jeunes
et là ça va être graves parce qu'il en
soit comme je le répète la même chose
aujourd'hui laissez nous travailler
nous savons de travail en un protocole
sanitaire qui est contraint nous savons
de travail et je pense que ce serait de
fermer nos établissements à 22h c'est
une erreur nous avons besoin de
travailler et nous sommes nous sommes
dans un éco 1 et cromitie de parce
qu'aujourd'hui la situation est très
grave
l'hôtellerie restauration jeanny marc
temps effectivement c'est l'économie en
tout cas l'économie de la restauration
qui va encore trinquer
cette fois
hertz les coeurs de ville il ya toute
une économie bien entendu les des
économies et des écosystèmes
donc c'est très compliqué c'est pour ça
que je suis désolée de me répéter mais
on avait les moyens d'éviter ce qui est
en train de se passer
et donc c'est d'autant plus rageant
et donc il faut absolument que le
gouvernement s'il veut aussi qu'ils
aient moins de critiques par exemple les
discours anti masqué discours anti
vaccins les discours c'est pas grave
après tout etc
il faut aussi qu'ils recréent de la
confiance est-ce que c'est avec une
conférence de presse comme ce soir dans
les vers en conte recréer la confiance
non à 90% non c'est évident donc on
allait vers une situation en aller vers
le mur et emmanuel macron faisait du
scooter des mers
enfin c'est quand même quelque chose de
très étrange
est-ce qu est-ce que nicolas sarkozy
faisait s'amuser comme ça pendant la
crise 2008 financière est ce que
françois hollande s'amuser comme cela
pendant les crises terroriste qu'on a eu
en 2014 2015
moi je reste extrêmement surprise et de
mémoire de politologues j'en suis
absolument désolé je n'ai jamais vu
aussi peu de capacité à l'anticipation
et donc à la gouvernance d'un pays c'est
très important
c'est ce que disait monsieur il ya des
choses qu'on aurait pu prévenir qu qu'on
peut anticiper on peut aussi d'être dans
la co création la concertation la
coopération avec les acteurs et les
actrices de terrain et sait rien de ce
fait c'est très visage une manière
permis et cette mesure également de
passer des rassemblements de 5000
personnes désormais à 1000
comment est-ce que vous la comprenez là
encore c'est efficace sont pas efficaces
je n'en sais rien à ce jour bien entendu
qu'il faut casser le plus possible les
chaînes de contamination ça je crois
qu'on a très bien compris et ça c'est
très important
donc forcément que maintenant
en ayant laissé filer juillet août voire
septembre on est quand même le vin et
quelques septembre de toute façon voilà
il ya une trois mois quasiment rien n'a
été fait et donc forcément
qu'aujourd'hui on prend des mesures trop
forte trop drastiques
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut aussi
peut-être tant pis qu'il faut faire il
faut faire un choc de mesures peut-être
pendant une semaine quinze jours pour
pouvoir revenir à quelque chose depuis
normal de plus rationnel et d'une
gouvernance qui est le meilleur est
beaucoup plus sensée et une gestion de
crise qu il cohérent mais sinon si
l'entreprise internationale gérer une
crise comme cela mais serait en faillite
dans la seconde
ça c'est plus possible aujourd'hui
étirez amouroux en tant que soignant
vous êtes rassurés quand même parcelle
ces mesures pour éviter la propagation
je parlais à l'instant justement de
cette mesure de passer de 5000 personnes
à 1000 personnes lors des rassemblements
ç'a un impact vous êtes quand même
rassuré non c'est un impact pour réduire
les manifestations c'est tout vous savez
il nous le renouveau tant que soignant
on a eu trois hommes trois mesures immo
qui viennent de s'enchaîner les unes
après les autres
la première c'est le décret sur la
reconnaissance
s'il vous pla thierry amouroux parce
qu'il nous reste quelques secondes en
quelques mots et puis marcel bénézet
ndir a eu le mot de la fin on vous
écoute
oui on vient de dire que la
reconnaissance des soignants maladies
professionnelles ce sera réservé aux
soignants décédés ou mis sous assistance
respiratoire
première chose deuxièmement un décret
pour licencier et le personnel
hospitalier et troisièmement au chu de
nice
on vient d'annoncer hausse régnante que
vous avez une pcr positif vous êtes
infectés mais vous continuez à soigner
les polonais les patients vous ne prenez
pas d'arrêt parce que toute façon ils
sont affectés donc c'est pas grave de
l'airé infectés donc voilà trois mesures
qui viennent d'être prises et qui vous
disent le mépris
envers les soignants et après voilà vous
comprenez que les soignants sont colère
sont maltraités parole alors à côté de
ça va réduire
c'est entendu c'est entendu
effectivement tirer amoureux c'est bien
entendu peut-être marcel bénézet en
quelques secondes le mot de la fin
oui moi je pense que ces mesures
n'auront aucun effet nos rendez vous
dans quelques jours ces mesures n'ont
aucun effet et nos continuera ça n'aura
aucun effet je pose assuré il fallait
nous laisser travailler
on sait faire rendez vous dans quelques
jours il y aura pas de baisse de
contamination y en aura pas du tout et
bien la zac
la date est noté une erreur de choix et
il pleut c'est comme ça la date est
notée rendez-vous dans quinze jours en
tout cas merci à tous les trois d'avoir
accepté notre invitation virginie martin
politologue professeur à la quête du
business school thierry amouroux porte
parole le syndicat infirmier sn pays
merci à vous merci à vous également
marcel bénézet président des cafés bars
brasseries syndicats jeanny est resté
avec nous sur rt france dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du discours du
président libanais michel aoun à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
alors que se tient aussi une session
spéciale pour favoriser la formation
d'un nouveau gouvernement crédible
puis nous reviendrons sur le projet de
pacte sur la migration et d'asile
présentées par l'union européenne qui
relance le débat sur les réfugiés a tout
de suite
[Musique]
rodolphe comberge vous avez découvert
que l'imagerie médicale qui était le
coeur de votre métier avait une
dimension artistique me suis aperçu que
c'était l'art qui faisait avancer la
science et la science qui faisait
avancer là l'image est belle mais mais
en général le mal qu'elle révèle il est
terrifiant au moment du coc vite quand
j'ai attrapé moi même
la balle a dit je me suis dit mais
pourquoi j'utilise pas ma technique de
3d de virton life a pour mon thorax
rod et pour le virus j'ai pu suivre son
évolution comme henry ça s'aggravait ou
au contraire comment ça c'est mac mais
quand on a découvert le coït on sait qu
on sait comment ils et comment
voilà quelle couleur il est qu'on a
découvert le mal
les matchs du mal
[Musique]
m
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france il est 20h30
heure française l'assemblée générale de
l'onu se poursuit une assemblée réduite
à des discours par visioconférence
coronavirus obligé cette deuxième
journée a notamment été marquée par les
prises de parole des pays des dirigeants
du maghreb et du moyen-orient des pays
comme l'algérie l'irak ou l'arabie
saoudite
mais aussi celle du président libanais
michel aoun son pays vit des moments
très difficiles la crise politique
sociale et économique est sans précédent
on les écoute
c'est le coeur du liban qui a été
frappée tant d'un point de vue
humanitaire que économique
la situation est critique n'oublions pas
non plus la crise des personnes
déplacées syrienne qui dure depuis déjà
dix 10 ans bien que le liban ne soit pas
un pays d'asile et que sa constitution
n'accepte pas l'intégration des immigrés
nous avons géré cette crise du
déplacement sur la base du principe
humanitaire et en respectant le droit
international notamment le principe de
non-refoulement le nombre de personnes
déplacées dans le pays et qui vaut
entière de notre population ce qui
exacerbe les conséquences économiques
sanitaire et humanitaire déjà difficile
le liban appelle à redoubler d'efforts
pour un retour sur une tueur est digne
des personnes déplacées
il faut trouver une solution politique
en syrie
surtout que maintenant la plupart des
territoires syriens sont sûres nous
voulons pouvoir compter sur une aide
pour la mise en oeuvre du plan de retour
des personnes déplacées syrienne alors
quel genre de relations entretiennent
les nations unies
et le liban on s'est posé la question
regarder tout commence dans les années
70 la tension le long de la frontière
israélo libanaise
présente depuis quelques années
s'accentue avec le repositionnement de
troupe palestinienne au liban le 11 mars
1978 une attaque en israël revendiquée
par les palestiniens intensifie les
tensions les forces israéliennes
décident alors d'envahir le liban en
quelques jours il occupe la quasi
totalité de la partie sud du pays
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu est
établie alors une mission nommée force
intérimaire des nations unies au liban
elle se compose de militaire et de
personnel civil international et local
objectif veiller au retrait des troupes
israéliennes assurer la sécurité de la
zone concernée et aider le gouvernement
libanais à rétablir son autorité
effective dans la région en 1982 les
forces israéliennes entre de nouveau au
liban la finul doit alors ajuster sa
mission pendant trois ans elle protège
la population et lui apportent une
assistance humanitaire
en 2000 les forces israéliennes se
retire avec les autorités libanaises la
finul poursuit l'aide humanitaire en
fournissant aux soins médicaux et
nourriture aux familles libanaises dans
le besoin jusqu'en 2006 malgré quelques
tensions c'est plutôt le calme qui règne
dans la zone d'opérations de la finul la
crise éclate en juillet lorsque le
hezbollah lance plusieurs roquettes
depuis le territoire libanais vers
israël le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
réclame une cessation immédiate de
toutes les attaques
un changement de contexte radical qui
poussent le nuage revoir la mission
après un conflit meurtrier entre les
deux pays la finul est renforcée à
l'issue d'un vote du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu en août 2006 la mission voix
notamment ses effectifs porté à quinze
mille soldats et appuie désormais les
forces armées libanaises dans leur
déploiement dans le sud du pays
après plus de quarante deux ans sur le
territoire libanais la finul est
reconduite pour un an le 28 août dernier
l'effectif est réduit malgré les
demandes du président libanais michel
aoun
quelques jours plus tôt israël avait
dénoncé cette mission jugés inefficaces
et pour parler du discours du président
libanais michel aoun qui s'est exprimée
donc en début de soirée nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
claude blanchemaison bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors nous venons d'entendre le discours
de michel aoun qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
en retenir sa discours relativement bref
mais très dense
d'abord deux premières parties il a
décrit la lah quadruples crise dont le
liban faisait l'objet une crise
économique et financière très sérieuse
qui dure depuis près de dix ans et
d'ailleurs il n'a pas dit que les
responsables libanais à n'avait pas
n'avait pas su traiter cette crise
deuxièmement la crise des réfugiés
il en a parlé en effet le liban et il
demande à ce que j'ai réfugiés syriens à
puisse repartir en syrie et que un jour
les réfugiés palestiniens puissent aussi
en repartir chez eux
et puis troisièmement la crise ducobu
comme tout le monde et quatrièmement
l'explosion catastrophique du port de
beyrouth avec la destruction de ce port
vital pour le pays d'ailleurs pour une
partie du proche orient et d'une partie
de la ville de beyrouth aussi il a
remercié les pays qui s'étaient qui
avait décrite déclaré des ventes
d'urgence en faveur du liban dont la
france est aussi remercié le pape en
passant et puis finalement il a souligné
que les pays qui avaient annoncé des
aides importantes donc les bailleurs de
fonds devait maintenant s'exécuter
c'est-à-dire verser ces fonds aux
autorités libanaises qui naturellement
les utiliserai dans le cadre défini par
les instances de l'onu
comme on le sait certaines de ces
certains certains de ces certaines de
ces aides sont conditionnées par des
réformes au liban
le président a uni n'en a pas tout parlé
à aucun moment
peut-être que ça n'était pas d'ailleurs
le lieu pour en parler alors il a aussi
évoqué l'intégrité territoriale du liban
avec le respect d'un certain nombre de
résolutions des nations unies en disant
qu'israël devrait notamment respecter
cette souveraineté y compris sur les
autres maritimes qui sont sous la
juridiction du liban d'après le droit
international et d'après le droit de la
mer donc il s'est invité par là dans le
grand marchandage qui commence en
méditerranée orientale sur les zones qui
contiennent des ressources pétrolières
ou gazières et donc le président
libanais naturellement a fait l'apologie
du cultural du multilatéralisme et de
l'onu est ton rôle au liban
alors lundi le président avait prévenu
que le pays se dirigerait vers l'enfer
sans gouvernement alors où est ce qu'on
en est aujourd'hui
oui alors un nouveau premier ministre a
été a été nommé il a été nommé avec les
précautions habituelles au liban puisque
comme vous le savez le
traditionnellement et en fonction
d'accords politiques qui ont été passés
il ya il ya longtemps
le président est chrétien le premier
ministre est sunnite et le président du
parlement et cite à présent si on peut
parler du parlement est d'ailleurs en
place depuis très longtemps depuis le
début de ces accords tripartites et pour
la nomination du nouveau premier
ministre on a nommé un technocrate un
ancien ambassadeur à berlin qui a été
dans des cabinets de premier ministre
libanais et ce premier ministre
évidemment états unis et à rechercher la
bénédiction de tous les premiers
ministres ils ont précédés mais il
n'arrive pas aujourd'hui a formé son
gouvernement parce que le
le hezbollah et les chiites et par
conséquent le parti du président du
parlement considère que les chrétiens
ont la part trop belle
c'est aussi un chrétien qui est à la
tête de la delà de la banque centrale
est un autre qui est à la tête de des
armées libanaises et par conséquent les
chiites veulent absolument le ministère
des finances est pas par hasard puisque
évidemment le ministère des finances
c'est la troisième signature il ya celle
du président celle du premier ministre
et celle du ministre des finances pour
toutes les mesures important le premier
ministre désigné
s'ils refusent d'ailleurs probablement a
aidé en cela par monsieur hariri qui
voudrait casser ce partage des zones
d'influencé surtout des ministères
régaliens et encore plus de ceux qui
peuvent rapporter
par conséquent on en est là la situation
est bloquée il faut faire preuve
d'imagination
je pense que les libanais sont capables
de faire preuve d'imagination
il est vrai que la date limite que leur
avait fixé monsieur mâcon est d'ores et
déjà dépassé
il faudra attendre un petit peu sans
doute pour que ce gouvernement soit
formé mais il sera probablement informé
avec deux jeunes technocrates compétents
mais qui répondront aux affiliations
habituel aux trois catégories qui sont
les catégories religieuse parce que
c'est le liban et on ne peut pas
transformer le liban
du jour au lendemain merci beaucoup
claude blanche maison pour votre analyse
je rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales
en europe à présent une réforme complexe
et déjà critiquée bruxelles a dévoilé le
très attendu pacte sur l'immigration et
l'asile il prévoit une meilleure
solidarité avec les états du sud de
l'europe terre d'arrivée des mes grands
et une procédure accélérée d'examen des
demandes d'asile il systématise les
expulsions des migrants dégoûté du droit
d'asile et préconise des contrôles
accrus aux frontières extérieures
de nombreuses ong accusent l'union
européenne d'avoir cédé au pays hostiles
à l'accueil des réfugiés
quand un mot clair la politique
migratoire européenne peut à nouveau
avancer un consensus a été trouvé ce
mardi
bruxelles a présenté son nouveau pacte
sur l'immigration et l'asile vouée à
remplacer celui adopté lors de la crise
premier enseignement lui soit renforcée
des contrôles aux frontières extérieures
dans ce nouveau système il y aura des
contrôles obligatoires sur toutes les
frontières
actuellement la seule obligation pour un
état membre dans le cas d'une personnes
arrivées illégalement et de prendre ses
empreintes digitales et de les
enregistrer dans ce nouveau système
toutes les arrivées seront soumises à de
rigoureux contrôle de sécurité sanitaire
et de vérification d'identité ce qui
permettra de rediriger immédiatement les
personnes vers la procédure appropriée
autre volonté de bruxelles à voir je
cite une efficacité accrue dans le
retour des migrants vers leur pays
d'origine
le pacte prévoit ainsi un processus
accéléré pour les migrants et un peu
susceptibles de bénéficier d'une
protection lié au droit international et
pour les pays réticents à accueillir des
migrants
ils devront obligatoirement participer
au renvoi des déboutés du droit d'asile
vers leur pays natal
ce nouvel accord est déjà vivement remis
en cause par des ong
parmi elles oxfam qui accusent la
commission je cite de s'incliner devant
les gouvernements anti immigration
la commission européenne a aujourd'hui
présenté son nouveau pacte sur l'asile
l'émigration au lieu de repenser sa
stratégie en faveur d'une plus forte
protection des demandeurs d'asile lieu
semble vouloir continuer avec sa ligne
hotspot accéléré malgré la volonté
affichée d'ursula von der leyen d'abolir
la troisième version du règlement de
dublin
ce dernier restera en vigueur dans le
cadre du nouveau pacte le pays
responsable du traitement d'une demande
d'asile restent donc le pays dans lequel
le migrant est arrivé la présidente de
la commission européenne se défend en
mettant en avant un équilibre je cite
juste et raisonnable
malgré les questions migratoires sont
complexes
l'ancien système mis en place en europe
pour y faire face ne fonctionne plus
l'ensemble des mesures proposées par la
commission sur l'immigration et l'asile
que nous présentons aujourd'hui permet
par conséquent un nouveau départ
véritable avancée ou compromis favorable
au pays anti immigration
ce nouveau pacte européen divise lors de
la crise de 2015 90 % des demandeurs
avaient obtenu le statut de réfugié
aujourd'hui deux tiers n'ont pas le
droit à la protection prévue par le
droit international et pour en parler
nous sommes avec pierre henry ancien
directeur général de france terre
d'asile et président de france
fraternité pierre-henri bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors ce nouveau pacte a donc notamment
a pour objectif de remplacer le
controversé règlement dublin mais aussi
de rendre obligatoire la solidarité de
tous les membres de l'union européenne
face à une arrivée massive de migrants
dans les pays concernés
est-ce que vous saluer ce pacte ce soir
d'abord nous n'en sommes pas à
l'élaboration et à l'adoption du pacte
de ce qui a été présenté aujourd'hui
c'est une note d'intention de la
commission européenne ensuite il va y
avoir un processus législatif c'est
complexe avec des allers retours entre
le parlement européen et le conseil des
états membres ton que nous sommes loin
de la coupe aux lèvres et
la note d'intention assez fournie qui a
été élaboré aujourd'hui par la
commission européenne
en réalité puis du neuf avec du vieux
je m'explique au moment de la crise
migratoire de thomis 15
la commission européenne avait sorti
toute une série de mesures assez
coercitive et qui d'ailleurs n'avait pas
bien il tape le mans a été mise en place
et donc aujourd'hui on assiste à ce
recyclage
je vous rappelle que la semaine dernière
la présidente de la commission
européenne sur la fin d'un vieil homme
disait que l'union allait abandonner le
système de dublin
en réalité il n'en est rien et à la
place ou plus exactement avec le
maintien du système de tubes lance c'est
une véritable usine à gaz qui est mise
en place
né dont il y à fort à parier que
beaucoup de mesures ne verront pas le
jour où alors seront parfaitement
inefficace je vais vous en citer une
l'union la commission prévoit de mettre
un certain nombre de hotspots
c'est-à-dire de lieux de rétention
frontières intérieures de l'union et aux
frontières extérieures notamment pour
les personnes demandeuses d'asile dont
la nationalité à un taux de
reconnaissance inférieur à 20 % dans
l'union européenne
autrement dit on va multiplier les
situations analogues à celles du camp de
maria sont sans souci si le meilleur
tient en rien des ong on le voyait
notamment dans le sujet le dénonce
ce pacte s'il est adopté cette grève
pour aux pays les plus hostiles à
d'accueil des réfugiés comme la pologne
la hongrie la république tchèque ou la
slovaquie est ce que c'est le cas quelle
est votre avis ah bah il est clair quand
que quand le chancelier autrichien
sébastien kurtz ou victor bad france des
sourcils
la commission elle reste de l'union
quand même tendance à se mettre au
garde-à-vous en tout cas à faire ou
alors sinon à faire des grandes
déclarations mais qui sont pas suivies
d'effets les 27 pays de l'union c'est
une communauté de valeurs c'est une
communauté de destin et tant que l'on ne
sanctionnera pas un certain nombre de
pays européens qui ne respectent pas la
règle commune bien chacun continuera à
faire ce qu'il veut et victor heures bar
et les pays des pistes grade et bien
continuerons à dire que lille ne veulent
accueillir
personne et sans aucune sanction ne sais
moi je suis profondément européen mais
je suis pour une majorité de projets je
crois que quand on n'arrive pas à
avancer à 27
il faut le faire avec les principaux
pays notamment sur cette question
migratoire d'accueil c'est à dire à 8,9
et puis éventuellement d'autres pays qui
viennent s'y joindre aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une efficacité globale
l'union européenne
il ya quand même du mal à exister aux
frontières le sujet est extrêmement
compliqué il ne faut pas le simplifier
c'est complexe mais ce que je pense
profondément c'est qu'il y à un corpus
de droit que l'union européenne doit
respecter et l'externalisation de nos
problèmes sur les pays tiers n'est pas
une option acceptable
autre élément il faut absolument que
l'union européenne si elle veut s'en
sortir est bien investi dedans pour
parvenir à une réelle harmonisation des
systèmes d'accueil et de procédures
d'asile tout au travers de l'union
européenne aujourd'hui c'est la division
la plus totale et je pense que l'union
ne peut pas se décharger de ses
responsabilités sur les pays tiers alors
ce pacte propose aussi peut-être pour
conclure à me mettre à l'abri des
poursuites judiciaires les ong qui sauve
des migrants en mer on en parle souvent
alors elles seront à l'abri mais est ce
que cela sous-entend que rien ne
changera finalement pas dû coûter
oui c'est le moins qu'on plie faire
sauver des vies en méditerranée c'est
dans l'adn de l'union de l'humanité et
c'est bien normal que les ong soient
exclus de toute poursuite mais la vraie
question c'est que fait-on véritablement
par exemple au méditerranée centrale au
niveau institutionnel pour sauver des
vies il ya des centaines des centaines
des milliers de personnes qui se noie
dans la méditerranée et comme l'union
européenne a retiré ses ports de
sauvetage de et de surveillance en
méditerranée bien il reste plus souvent
sur l'homme que bateau privé donc
je crois vraiment que cette question va
nous occuper encore quelques quelques
temps et que pour l'instant je le disais
en introduction de cet entretien nous ne
sommes qu'au début d'une note
d'intention qui vous ferait subir à
beaucoup de transformations puis je vous
rappelle
accessoirement que la présidence de
l'union européenne sera assumée en 2021
par le portugal et la slovénie et puis
au moment de l'élection présidentielle
de tobin 22 par la france et donc il y à
fort à parier que nous n'aboutirons pas
sur toute une série de textes avant
juillet 2022
merci beaucoup pierre henry d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes ancien directeur général de
france terre d'asile et président de
france fraternité et aux choeurs
également de plusieurs discours hier à
l'onu notamment celui d' emmanuel macron
la sphère alexeï navalni l'opposant
russe est sorti ce matin de l'hôpital
berlinois dans lequel il se trouvait
depuis le 22 août sur son compte
instagram le militant dit avoir encore
beaucoup de rééducation devant lui
les gouvernements occidentaux dont la
france évoque un empoisonnement présumée
à un agents neurotoxiques de type nos
vies de choc
ce que dément le kremlin pour qui je
cite il est libre de revenir en russie
chez pour plus d'information on va
retrouver notre correspondant à moscou
antoine gayraud les autorités russes
l'avaient prévenu moscou allait
répliquer aux sanctions européennes
décidée la semaine dernière dans le
cadre de la sphère navalni la porte
parole de la diplomatie russe l'a
annoncé dans l'après-midi et un
communiqué a été publié sur le site du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
la russie a donc élargi la liste des
personnes issues de l'union européenne
interdite de territoire russe maria
sharapova a de plus dénoncé la campagne
de désinformation qui selon elle est
dirigé contre moscou
dans cette affaire nous sommes tous
témoins d'une large campagne de
désinformation lancées par l'occident
les pays occidentaux
les dirigeants de ces pays les
responsables les institutions
les associations d'intégration dominé
par les pays occidentaux concernés
autour de la situation concernant le
citoyen russe
navalni d'autres pays occidentaux ont
également soutenu cette politique
intransigeante d'accusation en
particulier le président français
emmanuel macron a qualifié cet incident
de jeu site tentative d'assassinât il a
demandé d'ouvrir
je cite une enquête rapide et
transparente pour que je cite les
responsables rendent des comptes
d'ailleurs le président français a fait
des commentaires à ce sujet en public
même depuis la tribune des nations unies
concernant les sanctions brandie contre
moscou à la suite de l'emploi présumé
d'armes chimiques sur le territoire
russe
la réaction de la diplomate a été
cinglante
le secrétaire d'état américain mike
pompeo a menacé à l'unisson avec ses
homologues européens d'imposer des
sanctions contre la russie à cause d'un
supposé emploi d'armes chimiques contre
navalni nous considérons comme
inacceptable ce genre de rhétorique
il n'ya et ne peut pas y avoir aucune
preuves d'une supposée implication de la
russie dans cette affaire q comme ils
disent des traces russe comme la plupart
du temps depuis l'avènement des
sanctions contre la russie moscou a donc
répondu de façon symétrique aux
sanctions européennes
l'empoisonnement présumé de l'opposant
russe a jeté un froid dans les relations
entre la russie et l'union européenne et
la coopération dans les enquêtes est
actuellement au point mort l'ua demande
des comptes à moscou tandis que les
autorités russes regrette que berlin
refuse de leur transmettre les
informations qui leur permettrait d'
enquêter de façon efficace en
biélorussie alexandre loukachenko a
prêté serment pour un sixième mandat
alors qu'il est confronté à un mouvement
de contestation pour dénoncer sa
réélection le président entend bel et
bien rester à son poste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le jour de l'investiture du président et
le jour de notre victoire convaincante
et décisive
nous n'avons pas seulement élu le
président du pays nous avons défendu nos
valeurs notre vie pacifique notre
souveraineté et notre indépendance et en
réponse à l'investiture de loukachenko
des manifestations lieu dans les rues de
minsk elle des centaines d'opposants au
président biarrot lui se sont regroupés
dans l'après-midi dans la capitale pour
protester contre leur président les
forces de l'ordre sont intervenues avec
des canons à eau pour disperser la foule
il était encore quelques dizaines à être
regroupés en début de soirée selon
l'agencé interfax 50 manifestants des
tares et et je vous propose d'écouter la
chef de file de l'opposition svetlana
tirs à 9 sky cette soi-disant
investiture est bien entendu une farce
en fait aujourd'hui loukachenko a
simplement pris sa retraite
les pays européens soutiennent le peuple
biélorusse dans sa demande d'arrêter la
violence de libérer les prisonniers
politiques et de tenir de nouvelles
élections équitables et transparentes
ils sont prêts à fournir une aide réelle
il y a des plans d'investissement
sérieux qui sont envisagées pour la
biélorussie après la victoire de la
démocratie et ensemble nous gagnerons
et dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur les dernières mesures
annoncées par olivier vers en face au co
vide le ministre de la santé durci le
ton avec par exemple la fermeture des
bars et des restaurants dès samedi à
marseille puis nous parlerons de cette
tribune inédite celle d'une centaine de
médias qui publient
trouvèrent tout français pour défendre
la liberté d'expression menacée selon
eux par les fanatiques et les états qui
viole les traités en menaçant les
journalistes restez avec nous sur rt
fausses
[Musique]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter en partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche de l'intérêt de
leur population
[Musique]
14 juillet 2015 et signé à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président tron va décider de rompre
l'accord et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions au niveau international sur
1000 iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avait t'il un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen orient
[Musique]
pensez vous que malgré les apparences la
france joue un rôle dans l'élection à
venir en côte d'ivoire en france allait
voir c'est un cycle de polichinelle je
ne crois pas qu'il appartient la panse
des problèmes entrevoir le bénin
ouattara et son régime sont en train
d'imprimer leurs peuples il faut
demander au régime ivoiris de faire en
sorte d n'est pas crisper davantage les
positions la tension est déjà trop lourd
ou demander un report du scrutin prévu
le 31 octobre
organiser les élections en côte d'ivoire
dans les circonstances pareilles c'est
le conduit la côte d'ivoire dans un menu
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si seul interdit d'interdire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parlement qui vote de grands objectifs
massif à peu à la manière des plans
quinquennaux soviétique le soutien à
l'éolien c'est entre 70 et 90 milliards
d'euros
la facture d'électricité des français va
forcément montech désormais ses financés
par les taxes qu'ils reportent sur le
carburant là les fameuses taxes
d'ailleurs qui ont provoqué la colère
des de gilet jaune
en fait c'est au lit pour faire de
l'écologie et on paie assez difficile
d'expliquer aux gens que on laboure les
fonds marins ont détruit un écosystème
humain économique et tout ça pour le
bien de la planète
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 23 septembre 2020 en fonction
des territoires de nouvelles mesures
face au co lead dès samedi annonce du
ministre de la santé tout à l'heure
lille paris toulouse ou encore grenoble
sont placées en zones d'alert renforcer
les rassemblements ils seront limitées à
10 personnes dans l'espace public
les bars devront fermer à 22 heures
maximum les fêtes locales et étudiantes
seront interdites les salles des fêtes
et polyvalente seront également fermés
la guadeloupe et la métropole d'aix
marseille passait la zone d' alerte
maximale les bars et restaurants seront
fermés très cher à liberté d'expression
plus de 100 média co signent un texte ce
mercredi il appelle les français à la
défendre une tribune inédite pour l'une
des valeurs les plus fondamentales de la
démocratie
également placée en une de charlie hebdo
l'hebdomadaire satirique a été une
nouvelle fois menacé de mort après avoir
publié les caricatures de mahomet il ya
dix jours sa directrice des ressources
humaines a été exfiltré de son domicile
[Musique]
assemblée générale des nations unies
deuxième journée ce mercredi organisée
de façon virtuelle en raison de la crise
sanitaire
parmi les dix courses des dirigeants du
ghana du mozambique ou du kenya est les
pays africains qui souhaitent être mieux
représentés au sein du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu alors quelles réformes
quelles propositions pourraient être
mises en place ce sera l'objet de notre
face à face outre atlantique facebook se
prépare à affronter toutes les tempêtes
le réseau social prendra même des
mesures exceptionnelles pour contenir la
circulation de certaines informations
la firme américaine anticipe tous les
scénarios à la proche de l'élection
présidentielle américaine
avec la volonté de montrer qu'il n'est
plus un moyen de désinformation massive
comme dans les scrutins de 2016 ou le
référendum britannique sur le break site
[Musique]
olivier verra donc tenu son point presse
hebdomadaire sur l'évolution de
l'épidémie de kobe 19 et de nouvelles
mesures restrictives ont été avancés à
les précisions de notre reporter mona
mou dès lors devant le ministère de la
santé
la situation continue de se dégrader ce
sont les mots d'olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé lors de son point
presse
concernant la situation épidémique du
pays le virus est toujours aussi
dangereux et la situation est toujours
aussi préoccupante
les français les commerces le redoutait
et bien le ministre de la santé a
annoncé plusieurs mesures contraignantes
69 départements sont en rouge soit 7 sur
10 pour les zones d'alert il s'agit des
départements où le taux d'incidence est
à 50 cas par semaine pour 100000
habitants et des mesures ont été
annoncées concernant les fêtes ou encore
les mariages écouter seule une
disposition est désormais et sera
désormais imposé à tous ses départements
rouge les fêtes les mariages les
tombolas les événements associatifs les
anniversaires les communions devront se
tenir en petit comité
c'est à dire à moins de 30 personnes les
salles polyvalentes des salles des fêtes
et les autres établissements recevant ce
type d'événement devront respecter cette
jauge de 30 personnes paris lille
bordeaux ou encore lyon sont en zone
d'alerté renforcée écouter le ministre
de la santé qui énumère plusieurs
mesures concernant ces villes des
mesures qui s'appliqueront à compter de
samedi et à l'issue d'une concertation
entre le préfet et les élus locaux sont
les suivantes abaissement de la jauge
des rassemblements à 1000 personnes sous
réserve que les protocoles sanitaires
ils soient strictement respectées
interdiction des grands événements
déclaré comme les fêtes locales ou les
fêtes étudiantes l'interdiction des
rassemblements de plus de 10 personnes
dans l'espace public tels que plage parc
fermeture anticipée des bars l'horaire
de fermeture étant décidée par le préfet
après concertation des élus
cette mesure sur les barres entrera en
vigueur lundi pour laisser le temps
utile à cette concertation
en tout état de cause les bars ne
pourront pas rester ouverts au delà de
22 heures dans l'ensemble de ces
territoires
en revanche marseille et la guadeloupe
sont placées en alerte maximale avec
d'autres mesures encore plus
contraignantes et notamment la fermeture
des bars et des restaurants et ce propos
le ministre de la santé il s'agit tout
d'abord de la fermeture totale des bars
et des restaurants de la fermeture de
l'ensemble des établissements recevant
du public
sauf s'il existe un protocole sanitaires
strictes déjà mis en place
à ce titre les lieux culturels comme les
théâtres les musées les cinémas
on dispose de protocoles sanitaires
strictes et ne sont donc pas concernés
par les mesures de fermeture et par
ailleurs nous incitons au maximum au
télétravail pour l'ensemble des
activités pour lesquelles c'est possible
dans ces territoires
pour le moment ces mesures seront
appliquées à partir de samedi ou le
lundi pour une durée de 15 jours à
chaque fois avec la possibilité de
prolonger ou pas ce sera en tout cas au
préfet de le décider puisque des
concertations vont être engagées afin de
préciser toutes ces mesures dans les
différentes villes olivier vers ans a
également indiqué qu'il fallait
favoriser le télétravail là où c'était
possible si la situation venait à se
dégrader et bien lé territoire devront
passer en état d'urgence sanitaire
dans le même temps les auditions de la
commission d' enquête du sénat sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire se
poursuivent le sénat cherchent à savoir
comment le gouvernement s'est organisée
face à la pandémie de coronavirus et
s'il a fauté cib et n'diaye l'ex porte
parole de l'exécutif a été entendu ce
matin et elle a assuré ne rien avoir
caché à la population
du mieux possible avec les informations
dont elle disposait si bête ndiaye
attaqué notamment sur la politique
d'utilisation des masques au printemps
dernier créé le fait que les auditionner
prête serment
on voit que l'ancien porte parole à des
éléments de langage qui sont bien rodés
et ce qui m'a frappé c'est que en fait
elle ne l n'analyse pas les problèmes
qu'il a pu y avoir dans la communication
qui en fait ce ne sont pas des problèmes
de communication ce sont des problèmes
qui révèle la façon dont le gouvernement
a géré cette crise et à aucun moment
elle ne se remet en question où elle
remet en question les choix qui sont
gouvernementaux auditionné l'ancien
porte parole du gouvernement c'est
mettre en lumière le rôle démesuré de la
communication ce gouvernement est un
gouvernement qui privilégie la
communication pour justifier de ses
choix politiques mais malheureusement
sur des annonces qui ne sont pas suivis
dans l'effet de réalité
aussi pendant la crise du coc vide elle
a fait preuve d'un petit peu de
confusion parfois c'est quand même une
pro de la communication donc elle a su
faire passer certains messages et
étouffé certaines autres questions qui
pouvaient être un petit peu gênante
honnêtement elle avait un exercice très
difficile à réaliser parce que la
communication gouvernementale au mois de
mars et avril a été très confuse elle
n'est pas la seule à avoir tenu des
propos contradictoires sur de nombreux
faits que ce soit les masques par
exemple le premier ministre le président
de la république le ministre de la santé
on peut aussi effectuer des erreurs de
communication analyse a également
auditionné par la commission d' enquête
du sénat l'ancien ministre de la santé
agnès buzyn affirme que le dépistage
large échelle n'a pas été à l'ordre du
jour avant le début de la phase 3 en
mars dernier la question des tests de
dépistage à réaliser à grande échelle
n'a jamais été évoqué avec mes
homologues internationaux je crois que
la question des dépistages à large
échelle elle s'est posée au mois de mars
mais pas avant le temps qu'on réalise
tout ça et qu'on se mette dans l'idée
d'un dépistage à large échelle
c'était déjà contre la phase iii
commencé c'est-à-dire en mars pour tout
le monde en fait les experts et mai mais
je ne vois pas en fait sur quel signal
on aurait pu penser en dépistage à large
échelle en février pour voilà alors
peut-être que les allemands y ont pensé
leurs experts en tous les cas moi je
n'ai eu aucune note aucun mail aucune
demande aucun échange international ou
une recommandation de personne pour se
mettre dans l'idée d'un dépistage à
large échelle et pour revenir sur la
commission d' enquête du sénat mais
également sur les dernières mesures nous
sommes avec gilbert collard député
européen rassemblement national
gilbert collard merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors une
nouvelle cartographie présenté ce soir
par le ministre de la santé les bars et
restaurants fermés à marseille notamment
est ce qu'on pouvait éviter toutes ces
nouvelles restrictions les éviter howie
peut-être si on avait été au moment du
des confirmands - optimiste - estivale -
vacanciers j'en avais été peut-être plus
plus prudent dans ban dans ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la psychologie du
déconfinement c'est à dire ne croyez pas
que le virus est parti parce que le
déconfinement arrive on a vu à marseille
par exemple des touristes arrivés en
quantité et tout cela inévitablement
avec la circulation du virus devaient
mathématiquement s'il éthiquement
provoqué ce qui arrive alors on aurait
pu pour répondre directement à votre
question peut être éviter d'en arriver
là si on avait des confiné
progressivement et surtout si on avait
su installer une pédagogie du
déconfinement ce qui n'a pas été fait et
ce qui est très malheureux parce que les
françaises et les français se sont
imaginés du jour au lendemain
qu'ils étaient libérés du virus qui n'a
jamais été bien évidemment le cas en
tous les cas aujourd'hui sur la
situation olivier verrons a dit que le
gouvernement voulait être tout à fait
transparent notamment lors de ses points
hebdomadaires vous l'avez trouvé
transparent ce soir vous êtes satisfait
vous avez entendu les informations
principales
écoutez qu'il fasse la veux d'abord que
le gouvernement doit être transparent
c'est qu'il ne l'a pas été
rappelez vous il nous avait dit que les
militaires qui avait ramené les français
douanes avaient été
testez qu'il n'était pas positif
et aujourd'hui on nous dit que ce n'est
pas le cas effectivement c'était une
prise de parole de florence parly 2 la
ministre des armées je vous propose de
l'écouter justement et puis vous
réagissez ensuite j'ai juré de dire
toute la vérité et donc je me dois de
vous dire que j'ai dit quelque chose d'
inexact le 4 mars à france 2 c'était un
raccourci ce qui s'est passé c'est que
les équipages ont été soumis à un
protocole sanitaire extrêmement strictes
mais qui en effet ne comprenait pas à
l'époque de test n'étant pas médecin je
vous prie d'excuser le caractère un peu
raccourcie de ma formule voilà excuses
et le caractère un peu raccourcie de la
formule vous pouvez la comprendre vous
pouvez comprendre cette terreur de la
ministre des armées
non non non c c c c c'est vraiment nous
prendre le prendre pour des imbéciles et
ceux qui se surajoutent à cette pandémie
dont on ne connaît pas encore la fin qui
est en évolution en progression c'est
que la communication du gouvernement a
été en son genre insuffisante et erronée
ce qui explique qu'aujourd'hui les
citoyens et les citoyens de ce pays ont
du mal à à à croire les indications qui
leur sont données bompard elle nous
parle de 2,2 d'erreur versement
qu'objectivement du monde bon on a
affaire en la faire un gouvernement qui
croit qu'il peut par le parlement hier
d'une communication nous faire tout
avaler mais les françaises et les
français ne ne courait plus et c'est ce
qui fait que il va y avoir une grande
difficulté à faire accepter toutes les
mesures peut-être nécessaire qui vont
être mises en place
parce qu'on ne les croit plus et puis en
ce lien de confiance hilbert collard ce
lien de confiance vous estimez qu'il est
totalement perdu aujourd'hui entre le
gouvernement et les citoyens français
ah oui oui oui oui oui je pense que
l'accumulation des des mensonges ou
couteaux ou des erreurs fait
qu'aujourd'hui on se dit mais est ce que
quand monsieur vers ans explique par
exemple il ne raconte pas n'importe quoi
au moment où on nous disait comme au
moment où on nous disait que les masques
ce n'était pas utile
on continue à ne pas comprendre pourquoi
par exemple il ya eu une période pendant
laquelle on ne pouvait pas trouver de
masques dans les pharmacies de la même
chose pour les tests bon on nous dit
tout et son contraire
alors on est bien obligé de se demander
à quel moment dans cet amas de de
contradictions il y à une vérité et
c'est de nature anxiogène vraiment le
club la communication de ce gouvernement
sur ajoute à la réalité de la pandémie
une réalité d'angoise psychologique qui
ne fait qu'aggraver la situation et ça
ne va pas s'arranger j'ai l'impression
parce que quand on écoute le ministre de
la santé
on a l'impression qu'il cherche à
encadrer dans une espèce de rationalité
d'apparence statistique fait de courbes
une situation qui ne maîtrisent pas on a
en a le sentiment qu'on a affaire à une
apparence de rationalisation sur un
environnement qui échappe à la
rationalité gilbert collard pour
conclure en quelques mots hier le
premier ministre a rencontré les chefs
de l'opposition notamment votre
présidente marine le pen est ce qu'il y
à un dialogue entre l'opposition et le
gouvernement sur cette question de lutte
contre la pandémie justement c'est une
cause nationale c'est une cause
patriotique que de lutter contre la
pandémie
mais on doit aussi et c'est pas ça fait
partie de la cause patriotique dire la
vérité quand on a affaire à des
marchands de de bobards on ne peut pas
ne pas le dire aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on
peut les croire voilà la question qui se
pose et moi je
je doute voilà j'ai j'ai un doute qui
qui qui m'inquiète qui me préoccupe
parce qu'ils sont capables encore comme
ils l'ont fait de nous mentir
merci gilbert collard d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
député européen du rassemblement
national et dans l'actualité également
en france journaux magazines chaînes de
télévision et radios près d'une centaine
de médias ont publié ce mercredi une
lettre ouverte
alors que se tient jusqu'au 10 novembre
le procès de l'attentât
il appelle les français à se mobiliser
en faveur de la liberté d'expression en
soutien à charlie hebdo le journal fait
l'objet de nouvelles menaces depuis
l'art publication des caricatures de
mahomet c'est le directeur de
l'hebdomadaire risque qui est à
l'origine de cette tribune des médias
sont ouvertement désignés comme cibles
par des organisations terroristes
internationales des états exercent des
pressions sur des journalistes français
coupables d'avoir publié des articles
critiques alors cette tribune des médias
publiée en plein procès des attentats de
2015 un appel à défendre la liberté
d'expression menacée
cette chère liberté qui trouve ses bases
dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen de 1789 est elle
aujourd'hui menacée et l ange est elle
en danger on en parle tout de suite avec
nos invités
[Musique]
dominique pradalié bonsoir vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat national
des journalistes merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france avec vous alexis
poulain que l'on connaît bien
éditorialistes merci de répondre à nos
questions alors ce que je vous propose
avant de revenir sur l'appel de cette
cela centaine de médias français pour la
liberté d'expression
on va peut-être tout d'abord
s'intéresser à celle une autre tribune
publiée hier par une quarantaine de
sociétés de journalistes
c'était à propos du nouveau schéma du
maintien de l'ordre et de la liberté
d'informer je vais le site et un feu
vert accordé par le ministre de
l'intérieur aux forces de l'ordre pour
empêcher les journalistes de rendre
compte pleinement des manifestations
alors ce matin gérald darmanin parle
d'un malentendu
le ministre de l'intérieur s'était il
fait mal comprendre alexis poulain non
ce matin il mentait sur les ondes d'une
radio nationale parce que si gérald
darmanin aller en manifestation ils
verraient que et bien les policiers
demandent la carte de presse souvent à
des journalistes pour les empêcher de
passer pour leur dire de rebrousser
chemin de ne pas filmer ce qu'il se
passe en or manifestation c'est déjà le
cas aujourd'hui et pourtant la carte de
presse n'est pas obligatoire elle n'a
rien à voir avec le droit d'exercer ou
pas cette profession de journaliste et
de faire son travail c'est à dire être
témoin est reportée ce qu'il se passe
dans les rues de notre pays la france
donc qu'on le laisse mentir sur une
antenne nationale très bien ça aurait
été bien que journaliste prépare
l'interview et le reprennent en dix ans
mais je ne comprends pas quel malentendu
soyons clairs alors cette loi n'a pas
lieu d'être
parce que les lois sont bien faites il
ya une loi d'ailleurs qui protège la
presse c'est loi de 1881 sur la liberté
d'informer qui est très bien faite qui
n'a pas être touchés et petit à petit on
voit bien que les lois d'exception
encore de cette liberté de la presse la
réduisent et fait en sorte que les
français s'habituent à avoir de moins en
moins de journalistes qui peuvent faire
leur travail
c'est extrêmement grave parce que
derrière vient celle équilibre
démocratique qui est en jeu c'est la
façon qu'ont les citoyens de s'informer
librement auprès de journalistes qui
sont fiables et qu'ils peuvent faire
leur travail librement
chaque année la france dégringole dans
le classement mondial de reporters sans
frontières est encore reporters sans
frontières est très gentil avec le
gouvernement français
entre les violences contre les
journalistes de
par des forces de l'ordre et ça arrive
entre le contrôle des journalistes entre
la façon dont certains médias ont été
traitées avec des perquisitions au sein
de rédaction tout ça est bien ça qui
crée un très mauvais climat
c'est extrêmement inquiétant et ça
devrait être normal
et bien non ce n'est pas normal la
pratique du pouvoir aujourd'hui en
france elle inquiète les journalistes et
heureusement ils se sont réveillés ils
ont fait cette tribune maintenant il va
falloir se lever encore plus fort et
empêcher le gouvernement d'aller plus
loin dans ses mesures liberticides vous
qui tenez les comptes dominique pradalié
il ya eu beaucoup de journalistes
notamment de fuir en avoir été empêchée
de travailler lors de manifestations en
france
eh bien nous comptons à plus de 200 plus
de 200 les journalistes qui n'ont pas pu
travailler correctement sur les
mouvements sociaux notamment des gilets
jaunes mais jusqu'à la manifestation du
17 septembre dernier où deux nouveaux on
a embêté journalistes on les a mis en
garde à vue il y en a un qui a pris un
coup de poing directement de la part
d'une personne des forces de l'ordre etc
ça fait 200 e quelques bavures peuvent
survenir dans ce type de manifestation
on l'a vu au cours des âges ce qui se
passe depuis 18 mois est une totale
impunité des forces de sécurité pour
empêcher juristes de travailler cibler
directement visé blaise est directement
menacée injurié leur matériel saisi leur
matériel cassé leur matériel de
protection confisquer les gardes à vue
tout ça sans qu aucune plainte
aucun signalement l'igpn n'ai réussi à
faire son chemin
à ce jour et je rejoins alexis poulain
dans le fait que la liberté de la presse
c'est la loi de 1881 et que peu à peu un
ministre de l'intérieur après l'autre un
premier ministre après l'autre ses
forces de toutes les manières de
d'habitude les citoyens à ce que les
journalistes dont la mission est de les
informer
soient tenus en laisse nous disons donc
non et nous sommes ravis de voir que les
sociétés de journalistes ont fait
quelques jours après nous exactement la
même analyse ça prouve bien que toute la
profession dit non à cette espèce de le
manuel de dressage pro journalistes
alors outre aux tribunes on le disait
c'est cet appel d'une centaine de médias
pour la liberté d'expression face aux
menaces il signe et publie une lettre
une lettre ouverte à nos concitoyens ils
dénoncent notamment les menaces de mort
que certains reçoivent parmi les
signataires on peut noter france
télévisions rtl est la voix du nord le
journal du dimanche me nommant que
regarder par exemple les fps sollicité
par charlie hebdo a choisi de ne pas
s'associer à la lettre ouverte des
médias ensemble défendons la liberté la
réactions consternées du snj afp
dominique pradalié peut-être avant
justement sur ces médias mobilisés et ce
qu'on vient d'entendre
alors il n'est jamais trop tard pour
bien faire et l'ensemble des médias qui
ne s'est pas vraiment mobilisé à tout
instant pour charlie hebdo le fait
aujourd'hui tant mieux la fp n'y est pas
et bien c'est fort dommage et je trouve
que là il ya un manque est terrible
maintenant nous aurions aimé nous
aimerions toujours que ses employeurs de
journalistes qui ont tous été empêchés
trail et par les forces de l'ordre se
soient mobilisés ou se mobilise
maintenant pour eux exigé que les
journalistes des rédactions de même que
l'esprit de journalistes puissent
travailler convenablement et exercer
leurs missions
alexis poulain effectivement vous
partagez ce même mais ce même constat
que tous les médias ne se sont pas
forcément mobilisés pour cette tribune 1
contre eux
le nouveau schéma du maintien de l'ordre
et la liberté d'informer ils ont mis
bien du temps oui trop de temps je
trouve
sachant que là il s'est vraiment la
goutte d'eau déjà sur les violences
policières il a fallu des mois pour que
certains médias commencent à parler de
mes violences policières et et à
s'autoriser le terme est encore avec des
pincettes parfois il fallait surtout pas
utiliser le terme
je trouve que aujourd'hui il ya une
vraie hypocrisie de certains médias
propriété de grands groupes industriels
qui ne font pas un travail d'information
qui continue finalement d'être dans un
rôle de passe-plat d'organisation d'un
débat très policé où le gouvernement a à
peu près toujours raison fait toujours
bien les choses c'est pas le cas le
journalisme c'est porter la plume dans
la plaie s'est appuyé là où ça fait mal
et la critique sociale comme le disait
jaurès et je trouve qu'aujourd'hui on
est dedans un peu trop un journalisme de
connivence à journée de cours
parce que bien certains attendent des
mannes financières ou bien des marchés
ou d'autres choses de la part des
rédactions alors il ya toujours
l'indépendance des réactions c'est ce
qu'on dit
la rédaction est séparé de
l'actionnariat ça c'est ça c'est sur le
papier mais il ya un problème bien sûr
de citoyenneté dans les médias qui doit
être résolu les médias appartiennent aux
citoyens c'est pas à quelques grands
patrons de se faire plaisir en ayant des
médias c'est aux citoyens maintenant de
s'investir alors ça coûte cher bien sûr
la presse ça coûte cher de s'informer
mais l'on voit bien que ce secteur est
en crise avec une précarisation
grandissante des jeunes journalistes qui
arrive sur le marché avec des titres qui
ont bien du mal à survivre les aides
d'état qui sont là avec bien tout le
côté l'ès qui va avec l'aide d'états
évidemment et puis des médias publics
d'information qui deviennent finalement
des médias de un peu comme le rtf qui
sont là surtout pour ne pas bousculer
typiquement l'interview de gérald
darmanin ce matin sur une radio
nationale publique
on aurait aimé que les journalistes
aient un peu plus de mordant pour lui
poser les questions qui fâchent
voilà moi je trouve que les journalistes
ont aussi un travail à faire les
citoyens ou bien sûr à travailler à
faire pour défendre une presse
indépendante et libre et puis le
gouvernement doit arrêter maintenant
avec ces mesures liberticides mais je
pense pas qu'il va arrêter
malheureusement donc c'est à nous d'être
ailleurs c'est à tout le monde d'être
vent debout contre cette façon de renier
nos libertés de manière systématique
depuis les lois d'exception
dominique pradalié pour pour conclure le
mot de la fin pour rééquilibrer le la
capacité des rédactions à travailler en
toute indépendance
il ya une solution assez simple devant
laquelle avec beaucoup de lâcheté
plusieurs gouvernements ont refusé de
répondre
il s'agirait de reconnaître légalement
ce qu'est une équipe rédactionnelle et
de lui donner un certain nombre de
possibilités juridiques pour équilibrer
contre les actionnaires contre les le
marketing contre le partenariat ces
terrains qui minent ce travail et c'est
une solution assez simple mais il faut
un tout petit courage politique et ce
n'est pas le cas encore en ce moment un
grand merci à tous les deux d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci à vous
dominique pradalié je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire général du syndicat
national des journalistes merci à vous
avec six poulains éditorialistes et dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons sur
l'assemblée générale de l'onu et plus
particulièrement sur l'afrique qui doit
être mieux représentés à l'organisation
comme le plaide le président sud
africain est cyril ramaphosa puis
direction les états unis où facebook se
prépare à tous les scénarios possibles
pour l'élection présidentielle
américaine à rester avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]
quelle reprise économique pour l'après
qu'ovide 19
à quoi peut-on s'attendre on a été dans
l'oeil du cyclone cet été en fait ça
fait à peu près trente ans que la
croissance structurelle en france baisse
donc elle va continuer à être au mieux
médiocre et au pire catastrophique les
prévisions que peuvent faire le fmi ou
la deutsche bank a cédé prévisions au
doigt mouillé ça n'a pas grande valeur
si l'état était capable de relancer
l'économie la france est le pays plus
développés du monde beaucoup de pays
était déjà en récession donc le coc vide
n'a été qu'un catalyseur en fait de ce
qui s'est passé qu'une demi croise il
faut que ceux qui prennent des risques
gagne plus d'argent que ce qui entraîne
pas parler de croissance comprend toutes
les mesures qu'il faut pour que les
entrepreneurs ne gagne pas d'argent
j'ai un peu pas bien sérieux
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
dans les banques où la diversité c'est
un autre point fort pas l'autre point
faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs un
certain chohada et tout le monde discute
et finalement tu mon discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois voyez des images assez
touchants de l'armée qui était presque
impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
c'est la cause des hommes politiques ils
sont en train de manipuler l'armée on
sait très bien pourquoi ils nous tirent
dessus sais pas s'ils savent que c'est
leur fin ils se préparent le seul
langage qu'ils connaissaient la violence
il ne va pas être violent mais on va
rester
[Musique]
oh
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt francs si
vous nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française le 75e anniversaire de l'om
une occasion pour les chefs d'état
africains de renouveler leurs appels à
une composition équitable de
l'organisation la composition du conseil
de sécurité des nations unies en
particulier
pardonnez moi d'avoir faire une place
aux états africains a répété le chef de
l'état sud africain qui assure aussi la
présidence tournante de l'union
africaine l'afrique du sud siège
actuellement pour la deuxième année
comme membre non permanent a rappelé
cyril ramaphosa on les coudes suis vite
son homologue ghanéen a également
président de la cédéao la communauté
économique des états de l'afrique de
l'ouest
à l'occasion du 75e anniversaire de
l'onu nous réitérons notre appel en
faveur d'une plus grande représentation
des pays africains au conseil de
sécurité et que cette question soit
abordée d'urgence lors des négociations
intergouvernementales ce n'est par le
biais que d'un conseil de sécurité des
nations unies réformer et inclusif que
nous pourrons résoudre collectivement
certains des conflits les plus
persistants du monde
nous devons remédier aux injustices
existant depuis longtemps concernant la
composition des membres de l'onu et en
particulier le conseil de sécurité ce
que cela représente pour les pays
africains
le conseil a été créé en 1945 et la
composition de ses membres ne reflète
pas actuellement la réalité du 21e
siècle
le temps est venu d'adopter et
d'approuver la position commune de
l'afrique sur la réforme des nations
unies telles qu'exposées dans le
consensus des élus venez afin que nous
puissions créer une onu moderne adaptée
à notre époque les pays africains soit
être mieux représentés au sein du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu alors
qu'elle réforme quelle composition
pourrait-elle être adoptée c'est l'objet
notre face à face et pour en débattre
nous sommes avec dominique train qu'en
consultant militaire ancien chef de la
mission militaire française auprès de
l'onu dominique train quand bonsoir avec
vous par téléphone à guillaume ii ancien
conseiller aux affaires politiques aux
nations unies bonsoir messieurs merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors l'afrique doit être mieux
représentés au sein du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu dont la composition
actuelle ne reflète pas le monde dans
lequel nous vivons a plaidé hier le
président de sud africains
alors qu'attendent précisément les
africains aujourd'hui un siège permanent
dominique traquant voyez bien sûr les
afriques attendent un siège permanent
mais j'allais dire les autres pays
attendent une décision africaine parce
qu'il y a des années que l'on parle de
ce siège de membre permanent africain
mais le premier point c'est que les
africains ne se mettent pas d'accord
entre eux pour savoir qui aura le siège
est ce que ça sera le nigeria est ce que
ça sera l'afrique du sud
est ce que ça sera l'âge et l'egypte il
n'y a aucun consensus sur ce point là
donc c'est le point essentiel
je voudrais souligner d'ailleurs que ça
une certaine importance c'est ce format
de perm membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité le président poutine hier s'est
longuement étendu sur le sujet en disant
dans un premier temps il faudrait que le
pessac arrivent à travailler
correctement ensemble parce que depuis
mettons trois ou quatre ans le travail
du p5 n'est plus ce qu'il était et donc
il y a beaucoup de difficultés donc la
réforme du conseil de sécurité ça fait
des années qu'on en parle
les groupes régionaux ne sont ne sont
pas en mesure aujourd'hui de se mettre
d'accord c'est le premier point une
deuxième point il faudrait que les
membres permanents
présent aujourd'hui puissent déjà
travaillé ensemble pour qu'à ce moment
là on puisse admettre de nouveaux mans
traquant on reste avec vous parce qu'on
a un petit souci de liaison avec
guillaume blot en tout cas est-ce qu'il
est temps de faire évoluer
l'organisation des nations unies dans ce
sens c'est-à-dire repenser la place de
l'afrique au sein de l'onu selon vous
dominique trinquant alors la seule
question qui se pose c'est vraiment la
gueule à la question du siège permanent
parce que je rappelle que dans les
membres élus l'afrique est présente et
bien présente
donc il faut qu'elle puisse être
représentée au niveau permanent tout le
monde est presque d'accord je dis
presque parce que dans le discours du
président poutine
on n'a pas senti à un enthousiasme
débordant à passer de cinq membres
permanents à 6 ou 7 et de la part des
états unis on sait que la question ne se
pose pas aujourd'hui dans le
fonctionnement le coeur c'est bien les
membres permanents et donc si on veut
faire évoluer
c'est sur ce sujet là qu'il faut faire
évoluer on ne peut pas avoir un conseil
à 25 ou 30 membres
on voit avec l'union européenne la
difficulté ou avec l'union africaine la
difficulté qui a en multipliant les
membres donc c'est plutôt en multipliant
les membres permanents et le président
poutine rappelé aussi le problème du
droit de veto je rappelle que le droit
de veto il est utilisé essentiellement
par la russie et par les états unis
donc il ya une réflexion à voir mais
j'allais vous dire moi j'en entends
parler depuis je suis tout petit la
réforme du conseil de sécurité
et vous voyez que j'ai pu beaucoup de
cheveux donc ça fait assez longtemps
qu'on en parle et que personne n'a
abouti à une solution
on va pouvoir entendre guillaume d'eau
qui va vous répondre notamment sur cette
question et bien du siège d'un siège
permanent africain au sein de l'onu
qu'on le disait le président de
l'afrique du sud la plier dès hier mais
dominique train quand nous nous disait
mais au fond il n'y a pas de consensus
encore alors qui pour représenter
l'afrique le nigeria l'afrique du sud
j'y pensais pas trop qu'est ce que vous
en pensez qu'est ce que vous répondez
guillaume d'eau eux
merci que je suis parfaitement d'avis
avec monsieur cliquant sur le sujet la
question de la légitimité ou la question
de la représentativité permanente de
l'afrique 75 ans après une autre tuile
débat en 45
il était normal que les anglais et les
français parlent au nom de la colonie et
les temps évoluent et l'afrique sur les
questions de rue au nombre d'états de
population de richesses l'afrique compte
aujourd'hui il est évident que la place
de l'afrique doit compter au sein du
conseil permanent
guillaume douhéret permanent voilà c'est
ça comme membre permanent mais dominique
train quand nous disaient oui mais qui
oui la question de qui pour l'instant je
pense que les il faut d'abord se mettre
d'accord ou accepter cette affiche était
fait de cette étape à redon de fait que
la place de l'afrique comme si elle
permanent est important
après je pense que les africains entre
eux mêmes se mettront d'accord par le
nigeria ou le pays où l'afrique du sud
mais elle à la question pour moi elle
est primordiale du fait simplement que
ce soit acté dans un premier temps que
les ciels sont là présents et que ce
soit aux africains eux-mêmes dans des
filets qui va les représenter de façon
permanente de dominique trinquant
peut-être vous faire réagir sur cette
proposition finalement on a acté piquant
décide ensuite qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
non mais attendez les négociations sur
la modification du conseil de sécurité
ça fait à peu près 20 ans qu'elles sont
sur la table
on a essayé toutes les formules
possibles je me souviens très bien que
lorsque j'étais à new york l'ambassadeur
jean marc sablière qui était mon
ambassadeur a essayé des formules
différentes en faisant progresser les
choses et cetera mais le problème c'est
que à peu près tout le monde disait oui
on peut peut-être m
un membre de plus puisqu'on parle de
l'afrique
et ça pourrait être un africain compte
tenu de l'importance il vient d'être
souligné à juste titre de l'afrique dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui
mais à chaque fois ceux ci s'est heurté
à des discussions internes à l'afrique
où il ne se mettait pas d'accord parce
que de dire qu'on met un piège et
qu'ensuite les africains décident alors
ça se passe très très bien pour les
membres non permanents
parce qu'on sait que tous les deux ans
on va renouveler et que chacun aura son
tour seulement comme ça sera un membre
permanent le sujet n'est pas exactement
le même et là il n'y a pas d'accord et
on n'arrive pas à avoir un accord entre
africains pour que quelqu'un puisse
représenter l'afrique au conseil de
sécurité comme non permanents donc je
répète ça fait 20 ans qu'on en parle on
n'y arrive pas d'ailleurs je note que
dans les discours à l'assemblée
si vous voulez ça ne mange pas de pain
comme on dit de dire l'afrique devraient
être présentés devraient être membre
permanent bon très bien on a dit ça et
une fois qu'on a dit ça tout le monde
dit oui vous avez raison et comment est
ce qu'on fait et là on n'y arrive pas
guillaume blot alors justement comment
est ce qu'on fait est ce que vous avez
une idée justement pour que et bien les
pays d'afrique se mettent d'accord
trouvent un consensus pour être présenté
aujourd'hui au sein de l'onu moi je
trouve je trouve c'est de mon point de
vue purement personnelle puisque vous me
posez la question je trouve vraiment pas
loyal ou un fer comme disent les
anglophones
quand on demande d'abord premièrement
aux africains de se mettre d'accord de
béziers qui va être ou qui ne va pas
être des mesures dès j'allais dire
simplement des critères peuvent être
définies au sein du conseil puisque ils
en sont et de les imposer après sinon on
n'en finira pas monsieur craint qu'en
par le 20 ans on va encore entendre mais
l'autre d'année la question de lui quand
on regarde la question canton il ya de
l'intervention des les nations unies ans
quand tu aimes de métiers de la paix
dans la majorité des pays aujourd'hui
couverts en majorité c'est la prison va
prendre le cas de la libye
rapidement on va aussi regarder en à
science du nil dernièrement dans l'ordre
on parlait des africains solution
africain problème le propre imposer les
solutions africaines aux problèmes
africains c'est sale ça va aujourd'hui
de soi que la représentativité et là je
veux insister là dessus
la représentativité de l'afrique va
permettre effectivement de aux africains
eux-mêmes de participer aux décisions
qui vont prendre part que la question
des diplômes permanents ont pas mes
plats même pas le sujet c'est simplement
que les décisions se discute et son prix
les africains au conseil de sécurité et
ensuite on leur impose le mécanisme bien
évidemment que là il ya eu beaucoup
d'évolutions positives dans ce centre
aujourd'hui d'un mécanisme ou des
traités de dessiner canton régal
au niveau du conseil de sécurité au
niveau et le conseil de sécurité des
nations unies et le conseil de paix et
de sécurité de l'union africaine
travaille en étroite collaboration
puis les questions de déploiement des
forces dans les pays où il faut
maintenir la paix las il ya déjà
beaucoup d'évolutions ne par contre on
ne peut plus on ne peut plus il ya
beaucoup d'échecs par endroits parce que
simplement les pays d'afrique et non pas
qui part à des décisions qui ont été
prises ou conseil de sécurité et ensuite
on les met simplement au pied du mur la
question de la libye elle est toute
récente je crois qu'elle devait encore
servi d'exemple et de dire il est temps
de corriger la chose dominique trinquant
pour conclure le mot de la fin qu'est ce
que vous répondez à guillaume naud qui
nous dit que finalement et bien
l'afrique on a consulte pas et on lui
impose les choix de l'ol alors on a
consulte pas assez faux yade membres qui
sont élus régulièrement que représente
l'afrique et pour avoir participé aux
réunions du conseil de sécurité je peux
vous dire que chaque décision prise
concernant qui concerne l'afrique
ils ont leur mot à dire et bien sûr ils
votent et ils peuvent travailler auprès
des américains des français ou des
britanniques pour arrêter maintenant je
reviens je
sur un chemin on parle de critères mais
quels critères établir avant de choisir
la population la production je ne vois
pas quels critères on peut mettre en
place pour dire quels sont les critères
pour les cinq permanents
le président poutine l'a rappelé hier
c'est simple c'est les 5 vainqueurs de
la dernière guerre sssa lesquels seul
critère qui ont été retenus aujourd'hui
quels critères on va prendre si c'est la
population alors à ce moment-là la ddt
pour l'asie va dire moi je veux être
présent et la chine va dire non enfin
vous voyez c'est très compliqué
d'établir des critères qui vont
permettre de définir je crois que
d'abord il faut un accord entre les pays
de la sous région pour que ils disent
allez on arrête nos guerres et puis ça
va être un tel qui va nous et puis on va
peut-être mettre un manque permanent qui
va durer dix ans et puis on aura un
autre dans dix ans quelque chose comme
ça vous voyez est bien en tout cas un
grand merci à tous les deux d'avoir
partager vos différents points de vue en
direct sur ce plateau merci à vous
dominique train quand je rappelle que
vous êtes consultant militaire ancien
chef de la mission militaire française
auprès de l'onu
et merci à vous également guillaume dos
je rappelle que vous êtes ancien
conseiller aux affaires politiques aux
nations unies outre atlantique à présent
facebook se prépare à des scénarios
catastrophe pour l'élection
présidentielle américaine soucieuse de
se racheter une image après de
nombreuses polémiques au sujet du manque
de régulation sur le réseau social
l'entreprise affirme mettre les bouchées
doubles
le vice président de facebook promet
être prêts à parer à toute éventualité
même les plus dramatiques et quitte à
jouer le rôle de censeur explications
thomas bonnin le 3 novembre les
électeurs américains sont appelés aux
urnes d'une échéance prise très au
sérieux par les dirigeants de facebook
tant les événements pourrait tourner au
vinaigre
on sait par exemple que les résultats ne
devraient pas être connus immédiatement
car le vote par correspondance sera à
plébisciter en pleine pandémie
de quoi conduire certains acteurs de
l'élection à contester l'issue du
scrutin
nick clegg le vice président de facebook
s'est livré dans les colonnes du
financial times on y apprend que la
firme américaine
tout prévu en cas de circonstances
dramatiques
nick clegg par l'adoption d'urgence
prêtes à être mises en place au cas où
facebook ferait face je cite à des
circonstances chaotiques
voire pire violente on a déjà agi dans
d'autres parties du monde où il y avait
une réelle instabilité sociale et on a
les outils de toute évidence sans donner
plus de détails sur ces outils nick
clegg évoque la possibilité de réduire
la circulation de certains contenus sur
la plateforme
des précédents existent notamment au sri
lanka ou en birmanie ou facebook avait
réduit la portée de publication jugée
borderline mais qui ne l'est pas
forcément les règles sur les discours de
haine
il faudra donc peut-être s'en remettre à
nouveau l'arbitrage des dirigeants de
facebook
cette communication volontariste du
vice-président du réseau social vise
surtout à effacer la mauvaise image de
l'entreprise en matière de régulation
des contenus
voilà plusieurs mois que facebook fait
un grand ménage ciblant notamment les
propos haineux en juillet dernier mark
zuckerberg a affirmé devant le congrès
américain que 89% des discours de haine
était supprimée de manière proactive
avant qu'il ne puisse être vu par
d'autres utilisateurs
après le scandale cambridge analytica le
géant du web et désireux de montrer
patte blanche
encore plus en période électorale c'est
sans doute pour cette raison que
l'entreprise a lancé un vaste programme
visant à encourager ses utilisateurs à
s'inscrire sur la liste électorale
objectif inciter 4 millions de personnes
à s'inscrire mais derrière cette
apparente philanthropie se cache peut
être des but non avoué
c'est en tout cas la crainte de cette
professeure américaine spécialisée dans
les réseaux sociaux les entreprises sont
des entités politiques et nous ne
devrions pas croire que la plate forme
d'inscription des électeurs est fait
avec pour seul objectif le bien public
et n'est pas aussi stratégique leurs
efforts pour inscrire des électeurs
pourraient servir les objectifs d'une
entreprise et nous devons nous assurer
qu'il ne procède pas de manière
stratégique dans une voie qui pourrait
fausser l'élection et il ya
effectivement de quoi s'interroger quel
type de population est visée par cette
campagne fait
book cible hôtel indirectement un
électorat plus qu'un autre à vouloir
trop en faire pour ne plus être accusée
de laxisme facebook risque peut-être de
glisser vers d'autres dérives qui
pourraient s'avérer lourde de
conséquences et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis standford aux
états unis avec allen
or avocat c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur à la naure bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors c'est donc un sacré enjeu pour
facebook n'est ce pas oui tout à fait je
est il aussi important avec cette
nouvelle présidentielle aujourd'hui que
contacté beaucoup d'américains mélange
de tous les jours n'a pas été conçu
comme une chaîne d'information est un
réseau social où les gens pouvaient
s'exprimer et être en contact avec leurs
amis et leur famille
désormais j'ai vu aujourd'hui c'est
devenu une source de désinformation zone
informations biaisées prise de vue du
rct
les individus à agir d'une certaine
manière de croire en certaines
informations la nuit des élections
facebook
gagnon qui manque encore été consulté
par les autres les autorités alors cela
pourrait poser problème
juridiquement c'est finalement ce que
craint le plus la firme selon vous qu on
dise que le géant fait de la
désinformation que l'on dise que le
réseau a faussé le scrutin
de confiance abandonné parce que les
gens que ce réseau social de proximité
devenir louche et les gens pourraient
s'en détourner
et est ce que ce rôle que facebook ce
rôle de censeur que facebook pourrait
éventuellement revêtirait ce qu'il est
justifiée par la situation selon vous
parce que certaines de ces formations
qui sont vraies mais pas encore confirmé
et même à des sanctions
je ne sais pas si on pourrait considérer
que facebook serait dans le meilleur
sens heures que l'état américain en tout
cas facebook souhaite ne pas très de
paul îlotiers ce qui reviendrait à
appuyer feu très remplie donc il faut
essayer d'équilibrer moi je n'ai pas
beaucoup de principes et aux différents
traits fondamentaux pour les états unis
par exemple la liberté d'expression du
fait en même temps s'assurer que les
gens sont pas poussés à des actions
extrêmes donc facebook n'a pas
nécessairement l'intention de mettre 2
gb soda est en tout cas n'absorbe pas
les qualifications peut le faire et en
tout cas il faut que la situation soit
plus équilibré malgré tout est ce que
facebook tu peux jouer un rôle dans
cette présidentielle
malgré toutes les mesures qui vont être
prises pour éviter la désinformation est
ce que facebook aura un rôle pendant les
semaines qui viennent c'est le cas tous
les réseaux sociaux
ce sont soit des informations permet aux
gens de construire une idée voter c'est
un acteur d'un petit majeur des
informations produits par d'autres
réseaux je confirme les informations les
problèmes convient vraiment facebook
devient larbitre de la vérité on ne peut
pas tout avoir en même temps merci
beaucoup à la naure d'avoir accepté
notre invitation merci pour votre
décryptage ce soir je rappelle que vous
êtes avocat stanford aux états unis et
c'est la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve dans quelques minutes pour un
nouveau point complet sur l'actualité
rester avec nous sur rt france a tout de
suite
[Musique]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter un partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche dont intérêts de
leurs populations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]